hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Science Fiction
action film called The Matrix you ever
heard of it spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
[Music]
the movie is set in the year 1999 good
times and it revolves around a
programmer named Thomas Anderson who
works for a popular software company he
also moonlights as a hacker and is known
in the dark net by his Alias Neo
throughout his life Neo has had strange
Visions about something called The
Matrix however he has never been able to
decode his dreams one day while working
on the computer he receives a message
vaguely referring to his dreams and
instructing him to follow the White
Rabbit someone then knocks on the door
and when Neo answers he is greeted by a
group of ravers they buy illegal
Contraband from him and then invite him
to a party Neo initially declines the
offer but soon changes his mind and
agrees to accompany them when he notices
a tattoo of a white rabbit on one of the
girls the group then heads over to a
rave bar and there Neo is approached by
a woman named Trinity she makes it clear
that it was her who sent him the text
about the White Rabbit and the Matrix
curious Neo asks her to explain but
Trinity replies that she can only only
tell him that his life is in danger and
that he is currently under surveillance
following the strange encounter a
perplexed Neo returns home the next day
at work he receives a package in his
cubicle inside he finds a phone which
immediately starts ringing on the other
end of the line a man named Morpheus
speaks to Neo and warns him that someone
is coming for him he advises him to
slowly look up at the elevator Neo sees
three agents led by Mr Smith looking in
his Direction as a woman points towards
his cubicle Morpheus tries to help Neo
get out of the building but the latter
is so puzzled that he allows himself to
be arrested by the agents in the next
scene Neo is taken in for an
interrogation where he is informed that
he has broken every possible Cyber Law
in the country Smith tells him that he
is most likely to be headed for a life
sentence in prison but there's a way out
of this he can walk out a free man if he
helps the agent's nabbing Morpheus the
man who contacted him earlier Smith
describes Morpheus as the most dangerous
terrorist alive however Neo refuses to
comply and asks to speak with his lawyer
Smith then tells him that there is no
use of calling if he can't utter a word
just then Neo's lips become fused
together out of nowhere and he is
slammed on the table by the agents then
a shrimp-like probe is implanted in his
belly button uh been there dude the next
second Neo wakes up in a cold sweat in
his room he is left pondering if it was
all just a frightening dream suddenly he
gets a call from Morpheus who asks him
to meet at Adam's Bridge promising to
answer all of Neo's questions Neo
finally decides to comply and heads to
the location there he is picked up by
Trinity and two other people in a car
one of them points a gun at him and
orders him to take off his shirt Neo is
puzzled but Trinity assures him that it
is for their Mutual benefit that he must
comply he hesitantly obliges and
shockingly Trinity pulls out the device
that the agents had implanted in his
body it turns out Neil wasn't dreaming
after all Trinity then takes him to an
abandoned building where they reunite
with Morpheus the mysterious man tells
Neo that all the answers he has been
seeking all his life can't really be
explained they can only be seen and
experienced Morpheus then warns Neo that
once he learns the truth he can never go
back afterwards Neo is given the
decision blue pill or red pill the first
pill shall take him back to his old life
with no recollection of his meeting with
Morpheus Trinity and the others while
the red pill will make him extremely
social and touching stuff will feel
great for a couple hours actually the
red pill will keep him in the Wonderland
and Morpheus will show How Deep The
Rabbit Hole goes after a brief
deliberation Neo obviously chooses the
red pill meaning he wants to learn the
truth so he is strapped to a chair and
fitted with some wires to his shock he
sees a shattered mirror miraculously
repair itself puzzled and intrigued he
touches the surface and lo and behold
the silver begins to creep over his skin
meanwhile morpheus's crew attempts to
locate something on the monitors
eventually the silver fluid completely
covers Neo and he blocks out the movie
makes a really cool noise here that's
like oh
he then wakes up in a pink embryonic pod
hairless and naked there are several
black tubes attached all over his body
like he has become some sort of a lab
rat after a while Neo emerges from the
Pod and shockingly learns that he is
surrounded by Tower after Tower of Paws
all filled with humans soon a hovering
robot nurse spots him moving and he is
swiftly discarded into the gutter
countless human lives reduced to the
function of mere batteries for the
machines as Neo is about to sink in the
waste a hovercraft appears and he is
hauled into the ship's cargo bay to his
relief the craft belongs to Morpheus and
he reunites with him and his crew now
clad and simple hand knit garments as
Neo begins to lose Consciousness
Morpheus says Welcome to the Real World
Nia's muscles of atrophied after
apparently having been in a state of
coma his entire life he also experiences
pain in his eyes which is due to him
having never used them before therefore
Morpheus and his crew spent the next few
weeks treating his body one day Neo
finally gains Consciousness he is fully
clothed and has grown some hair on his
head Morpheus then appears and informs
him that they are inside his ship called
the Nebuchadnezzar moreover it's the
year 2199 not 1999 as Neo and others in
his world were made to believe he then
gets a tour of the ship and is
introduced to the rest of the crew apoc
Cipher Mouse and brothers tank and Dozer
The Crew straps Neo onto a chair and
inserts a long probe into the back of
his skull the very next second Neo finds
himself in an all-white world with
Morpheus he has a head full of hair and
he no longer has sockets all over his
body Morpheus explains that the white
space is actually a computer program and
they can turn into anything they want
that shares and TV in front of them are
not real they are simply computer
generated virtual realities Neo has then
shown footage of a modern city which he
knew as his real world Morpheus reveals
that this world is a neural interactive
simulation which he calls The Matrix
next Neo learns about the actual real
world which is revealed to be a dark
desolate emptiness with a shrouded Sky
it turns out at the end of the 20th
century humans and AI machines fought a
war against each other at that time the
AI machines were powered by solar energy
so the humans blotted out the sky in an
attempt to defeat them however the AI
machines outsmarted the humans enslaved
them and used them as the main power
source of their world they made use of
the 120 volts of electricity and 25 000
BTUs of body heat generated by the human
body to power themselves when the demand
increased the AI started farming humans
in a vast field connecting them to their
outlets and entrapping them in their
pods the world Neo has known as his is
just a matrix and it is a
computer-generated World created to keep
humans under control so that they can be
used as a power source Morpheus and his
crew are the only free humans along with
the citizens of a city called Zion it is
the last remaining human City hidden
deep beneath the ground near the Earth's
core turns out Morpheus and his team
regularly hack their way into the Matrix
using telephones to free More Humans
from slavery machine programs control
the Matrix the agents that Neo
encountered earlier are examples of
machine programs that can take over any
human in the Matrix that is under their
control meanwhile there are autonomous
machines called the Sentinels that
operate in the real world they Patrol
the ancient sewers and passageways of
the dead human cities in search of
humans who may have woken up from the
Matrix Neo is overwhelmed by the
Revelation so he pukes and passes out
later when he comes to terms with
reality he has taught a series of
martial arts techniques including
Taekwondo drunken boxing and Kung Fu I
know Kung Fu I know crochet I know how
to play fortnite I know how to be
obnoxious about craft beer in a matter
of hours with the help of computer
simulation Neo's performance amazes
Morpheus and he is reminded of a
prophecy made by someone named The
Oracle who prophesied that Neo will free
humankind from machine slavery next Neo
learns how to free his mind and jump
from one building to another in The
Matrix he is warned that if he dies
inside the Matrix he will also die in
the real world that day a sentinel comes
close to detecting their presence but
the crew manages to hide in the huge
sewer system by disabling their power
the following day Morpheus Trinity apocs
switch Mouse Cypher and Neo go inside
the Matrix to meet the Oracle however on
their way to the destination Cipher
secretly discards his cell phone for
some reason the group eventually arrives
at the oracle's home and it turns out
that she raises potentials a group of
children who possess specific qualities
of Enlightenment and awareness when Neo
introduces himself to the Oracle she
surprisingly tells him that he is not
the one and one day he will have to
choose to save either Morpheus or
himself later when the group proceeds to
head back they are ambushed it turns out
that Cipher sold them out he had gotten
tired of fighting for the liberation of
humankind so he now wants to go back to
his ignorant yet Blissful Life in The
Matrix the agents spray the group with
bullets and it results in Mouse's death
tank manages to help the rest of the
crew escape through the walls however
they are soon spotted by an agent so
Morpheus sacrifices himself so that the
others can escape after a bit of a scare
Trinity and the group managed to escape
but Cipher returns to his real body back
in the Nebuchadnezzar before them he
immediately kills the unsuspecting tank
in dozer before starting to unplug the
crew in the real world one by one
however before he could get to Trinity
tank who is somehow survived the attack
gets up and shoots Cypher dead in the
next scene Trinity and Neo safely make
it back to the ship while agent Smith
interrogates Morpheus about the city of
Zion afraid that Morpheus will spill
their secrets tank suggests unplugging
him but Neo says no he remembers Oracle
telling him that he is not the one but
he can choose to save Morpheus hence Neo
decides to bring back Morpheus by
sacrificing himself Trinity is impressed
by his determination and she decides to
join him as well after arming themselves
with a plethora of weapons the two head
to the building where Morpheus is capped
they shoot their way past the guards and
make their way to the left they then
climb to the top of the building through
the cable and blow up the lobby with a
bomb on the roof they are attacked by
police who are remotely controlled by
the agents a long battle follows but Neo
eventually manages to neutralize the
police and board their Chopper along
with Trinity the pair fly the helicopter
and hover it around the floor where
Morpheus has been held hostage they then
opened fire at the agents compelling
them to take shelter Morpheus uses this
opportunity to escape and jump towards
the chopper meanwhile Neo immediately
ties himself to a rope and jumps out to
catch Morpheus they get hold of each
other but the agents managed to sabotage
the helicopter so the two are forced to
jump on top of one of the buildings
meanwhile as the chopper crashes Trinity
grabs the rope and jumps Neo quickly
saves her and seeing this Morpheus
exclaims you are the one Neil reminds
him about their last encounter with the
Oracle but Morpheus replies that she
told him exactly what he needed to hear
reverse psychology never fails following
this the three quickly Rush In inside a
Subway and locate a telephone booth
Morpheus and Trinity managed to escape
but Neo is confronted by agent Smith
left with no choice he decides to take
on the deadly agent resulting in a
brutal fight as expected Smith
overpowers our hacker boy with his
nearly Invincible moves not even the
fabled throat flicks can take him down
he throws Neo into the train tracks and
puts him in a headlock soon the train
approaches but Nia somehow backflips off
the tracks leaving the agent to die
however Smith takes over another human
and starts chasing Neo at the same time
the Nebuchadnezzar comes under attack
from the Sentinels tank and the crew
prepare to launch an electromagnetic
pulse against them but they can only do
so once Neo returns meanwhile the latter
evades attacks from Smith as he is
Guided by tank into a building
unfortunately just as he enters room 303
the agent catches up to him and shoots
him several times in the heart killing
him instantly the situation is even
worse at the ship the Sentinels have
begun tearing the place apart with time
running out Trinity becomes emotional
and leans over Neo's lifeless body
confessing that the Oracle had
prophesized she would fall in love with
a man and he would be the one as the
sentinel's lasers begin to cut open the
hovercraft Trinity confesses her love
for Neo and kisses him necrophilia Saves
the Day lo and behold he wakes up the
agents notice him and without wasting
any time they open fire however Neo
telekinetically stops the bullet's
mid-air and drops them on the ground
making for one of the most epic movie
scenes of all time Neo has embodied the
one and he begins to see through the
Matrix he sees Cascades of machine codes
and using his Newfound Powers he defeats
Smith effortlessly before returning back
to the ship just then Morpheus launches
the EMP and destroys the Sentinels when
Neo opens his eyes he finds Trinity
leaning over him so he gives her a kiss
the movie ends with Neo continuing to
fight to free humankind from AI slavery
he re-enters The Matrix and takes flight
proving that he is the one then Shad
Kroger Cuts in on the mic and goes three
new year old save us sorry I got the
wrong movie there
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching